le forum des arts charles aznavour à
montigny le bretonneux a revêtu son plus
bel écrin le samedi 26 mars pour les
inimités les habitants pouvaient
découvrir ce bâtiment de 3500 m² qui
rassemble le conservatoire de musique
l'école de théâtre et deux associations
de danse on a une vie culturelle
foisonnante sur montigny avec des gens
qui sont très motivés qui ont leur vie
et on s'est dit qu'il fallait leur
donner l'équipement qui correspondait à
16 ans s'approprie la salle avec plaisir
les locaux tout est beau donc ça fait
plaisir dans des vrais locaux ont été
éblouis par les salles par leurs
vêtements les miroirs les bars on a
l'impression d'être une compagnie
professionnelle et je pense qu'on danse
bien mieux depuis qu'on est là un
auditorium de 150 places des studios
d'enregistrement et de répétition des
studios de théâtre et de danse le lieu
offre un équipement de meilleure qualité
et adaptées aux différentes pratiques
quand on joue j'ai trouvé que l'
orchestre
était un peu décuplée je trouvais qu'on
entendait plus les instruments on on
avait une meilleure appréciation de ce
qu'ont joué et
bah c'est satisfaisant en fait non on a
eu besoin de prendre nos marques c'est
vrai que ça change beaucoup en terme d'
espaces de revêtement au sol des bars on
retrouve des barres mobiles qu'on
n'avait pas avant un lieu qui permettra
aux trois disciplines de s'exprimer
individuellement mais aussi
conjointement c'est une chance
incroyable d'avoir un lieu où nous nous
retrouvons tous c'est une ruche il y à
des musiciens des danseurs des théâtreux
c1 donne envie de faire plein de projets
interdisciplinaires
au total plus de 1800 élèves sont
inscrits dans les différentes écoles un
conservatoire des arts plastiques
devrait également s'installer sur place
par la suite
[Musique]